Daniel is in Midland Texas hi Daniel how
are you doing good sir thank you very
much for taking my call sure what's up
oh not a whole lot I just have a
question for some strategic advice I'm
30 years old and I have roughly seventy
seventy-five thousand in debt and
currently I work in the local and I make
about 85 90 thousand a year I've paid
off probably twelve sixteen about
eighteen thousand of it over the past
year and a half that I've had this job
I'm just trying to see if there's a way
I can knock it out a little quicker
you're single yes sir no kids okay
where's all your money going you're
making more money never made your life
yes sir the only one of the most biggest
parts of it is rent in Midland Texas is
two thousand twenty or twenty two
hundred dollars a month for a
one-bedroom apartment
okay that's starting to happen thirty
thousand dollars a year you make ninety
yes sir and then the the where the debts
coming from that I pay on every month is
a truck a timeshare that I had from when
I was twenty five credit cards and then
about six or seven thousand that I owe
my parents and back young and dumb
mistakes
gotcha okay and what do you all on the
truck say that against there how much do
you owe on your truck
I had a thirty eight thousand from fifty
four thousand
what would you say if I said your truck
was insanity understandable and the
reason the reason why I got it to be
honest with you day was uh you know I
worked all whole life tried to do
everything that I could I didn't
complete college and I was actually got
a job so you deserve to be burdened with
debt no sir no no sir this is where
you'll award yourself this to be
burdened with that no Sarah and that's
understand exactly what you're saying
bail me out and the truck might have
been a step a little quick to it yeah or
but I had never bought anything nice
before so that was the kicker
as long as you keep believing that crap
you're probably going to be in debt yes
sir
you don't deserve you don't deserve the
truck yes because the truck's not a
blessing dude it's a curse you call me
because you're deep in debt and a half
of it is a stinking truck so I got a
nice truck
I got a raptor they're nice I want you
to have a nice truck I just want your
nice truck to have you and this one's
got a choke hold on you tap out right
yes sir that's what I would do so here's
the thing I you know if you save up and
pay for something you've earned it you
deserve it and you will enjoy it a lot
more but right now every time you put
the key in the ignition on that thing
you have mixed feelings yes I love my
truck and oh my god this thing's killing
me right that that's those all those
things go through your head
simultaneously don't they yes sir yeah
and that's because so what I would do if
I woke up in your shoes is I would get
on beans and rice rice and beans have no
life get on a written plan and I would
be debt-free in 18 months and that's if
you keep the truck okay but listen if
you're not going to tune lown where you
have no life all you do is work barely
eat keep the lights on pay the rent on
time I don't want to hear about you
going anywhere else you've got it if
you're going to keep this truck now
otherwise otherwise sell the truck and
you'll be dead free in about six months
right very true but if you want to keep
the truck it's it's out of control it's
a little high okay it really is if you
want to keep it though you've got to
commit to going absolutely crazy
where you're broke friends think you've
lost your mind
yes scorched earth you following me yes
because otherwise this truck there's no
way it makes sense you start telling
it's going to take me four years to get
out of that and eighteen thousand is a
good you've made progress
congratulations but your progress is too
slow it's why you called me at the so
I'm gonna punch this thing in the face
so hard the situation that it just falls
over correct and this intensity is how
that I'm describing is
people get out of that so list your
debts smallest and largest pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one jump online start using every dollar
calm it's free it's a budgeting tool
that will show you how to put your
budget together in about 10 minutes and
then you don't do anything no life
complete target I'm going to keep the
truck and I'm going to do nothing in 18
months I'm going to be debt-free if
you're not willing to do that sell the
truck okay and next time you get ready
to buy something that you deserve if you
can't write a check for it hear my voice
in your ear you don't deserve it if you
can't write a check for it yes
completely understand no man you're a
good man you're a hard-working dude I
know that about you because you're
working oil fields and you're probably
working a bunch ot aren't you why I'm
actually in sales then it's on me not my
phone is overtime but now as far as what
I do I'm the one that actually keep your
company afloat by going putting jobs on
Ford
phone rings 365 24 7 all night yeah so
you're going hard already yeah so it's
not you're not you in my point is you're
not used to coming home and sitting with
your feet up for seven hours anyway
you're right exactly so you're you're
used to leaning in the stuff you know so
you can lean into this situation the
same way you've leaned into your career
and you'll be able to knock this thing
out in no time hold on I'm going to send
you a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover if you're driving a lot you can
tell Kelly that she'll give you the
audio version if you want that instead
you might rather have that in the truck
or have that on your you know your
iPhone or something so you can I'm sure
this truck has Wi-Fi in it or bluetooth
in it so thanks for the call dude open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five a couple rules of
thumb on cars folks number one if you
can't pay cash don't buy it
number two the total of your vehicles
all your vehicles added up cars boats
sea-doos trucks motorcycles whatever it
is tractors it's got a motor in it add
it all together if it's more than half
your annual income you have too much
tied up in things that are going down in
value
you're too many cars too much to
expensive a car whatever it is so you
make $30,000 a year you don't need a
$20,000 car that's my point
because it's going down in value and
it's thinking you and you know you're
not out earning the loss and value that
appreciation so the total of your boats
cars trucks tractors sea-doos
motorcycles should not airplanes should
not be more than half your annual income
whatever's got a motor in it is going
down in value and I'm a boy so I like
everything that has a motor in it period
whatever it is I like it and I don't
have one of every one of them but I've
got a lot of them I like them but that
doesn't mean that where they will ruin
your life because they all go down in
value they all break and they all have
to be replaced and the last thing you
need America is a freaking car payment
it'll ruin your life this is the Dave
Ramsey chef
you